welcome back to new rockstars the second
episode of loki confirmed what we've
been speculating about for months
that causing much of this chaos is a
female loki variant but
what if she's not the actual villain the
tva is making her out to be
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the
titles we
love i'm eric voss going rogue with me
today is empty
hey what's going on buddy what's going
on everybody let's get rogue
let's get rogue also here with us it's
jess clemens hello
jessica i need a hero
oh sorry i love this episode and the
beginning of it was really good
i'm so excited to talk about episode two
and joining us today special guest our
friend and comedian matt acevedo
hey it's good to be back what's up
everybody hello what's going
on all right let's talk about this
episode of loki so
in the second episode we finally meet
the loki variant that the tva has been
hunting down
sophia di martino playing a female loki
now this could be lady loki just based
on the tva identifying her as
a loki variant uh loki sex being listed
as fluid on the forums
that one broken horn on her crown that
you know that kind of looks like how
lady
loki looks in the comics but really this
whole idea that uh this woman
might be a female body that loki's soul
possessed since we know they can do kind
of soul swapping
consciousness swapping with this version
of the character but
if you look at this episode's
international credits and actually
another
clue that you see earlier in the episode
on forum where it says uh
sylvie lauffy deutsche which is like a
laughy daughter instead of laffy's son
we think this character could just be
named
sylvie uh which might make her based on
sylvie lushton
enchantress from that same comic run so
we're not really sure exactly what
direction they're going
i'm thinking it could be just a mix of
both characters like maybe after loki's
death by thanos
infinity war his soul might have
reattached to some oklahoma woman named
sylvie uh and then
and that became the state transparent or
or there's some other alternate timeline
where
instead of laufey's son it became laughy
daughter you know and that's who sylvia
is
um but we have to ask do you think this
female variant could be working
on behalf of or maybe against some
greater threat
uh because they introduced her so early
so what do you think this female
variance connection will ultimately be
with the core conflict of this series
is she the big bad or is there someone
else in the shadows still
i don't think that this lady loki or the
sylvie character whoever
she ends up being is going to be the big
bad of the series because like like
jess said before we do hear that i need
a hero when she first you know appears
and kills all those people
and though killing is not does not make
you a hero end up
saying that right now um she does you
know loki
does tend to you know when he is this
like
you know good person he does do good
things in like a not so great way
so i think that we have this loki
variant you know potentially
being a hero but but killing all these
people for her own ends and i think that
the mysterious
real villain of the show could actually
be mobius
um because i really do think that mobius
is loki i know this sounds
crazy um and this is why i'm bringing it
up on
rogue theory because i'm going real
rogue here but like
there's just something about the way
that the show is shot and like the
the conversations between loki and
mobius that like makes me feel like
lady loki is going after mobius himself
she wants mobius
specifically and um mobius is like all
right
i'm not gonna go out and expose myself
i'm gonna let
you know the tva agents get killed and
like he's just trying to bring down
this lady loki specifically because she
has his number he
she wants him dead so i mean don't you
think if she was after mobius she had
like the god's eye view of that entire
superstore
why would she have gone to b15 and loki
and uh
like mess with them why wouldn't she
just walked over to mobius and mess with
him and
because ah this is true this is true i
don't know maybe they
work in mysterious ways but i just don't
trust mobius loki i just
i think that there's a grander plan
going on and like
via time travel maybe like mobius loki
or
or she knows more information that we
are not privy to which is why she did
what she did
you know what i was thinking mtv when i
was watching this episode i
kept being like mt is so he thinks
mobius is a loki
i need to pay attention to like
everything he does to see what is loki
of him
and then i was like what is the so i'm
asking you this question i guess
what is the chance that he is like he
who remains what if he
is what if mobius is the oldest living
time like keeper
what if he because like i feel like in
the comics yeah he's old and whatever
and like
prehistoric but what if in this he's
just someone that doesn't really age
in the tva and he's undercover or not
even undercover he's just like
yeah i'm the oldest variant and you're
[ __ ] all this stuff up and how can i
get in this but with just working closer
to you
do you think that's a situation that
could possibly happen are you just so
you're like no he hasn't no i like first
of all i like how you said undercover
because you just described undercover
boss
because he remains hiding in the tva
i'm spying on my employees today making
sure that they're doing well yeah oh
that is
wait talk to snl do this another sketch
do another sketch of this you can direct
that's actually a great idea no one
copies it that's actually you know to
get on to mt's theory though
you know i didn't think about this i'm
not gonna lie you came in guns plays i'm
like whoa
look at that uh but to add on to it
there is this really great exchange
between
uh between loki uh and um mobius
and and that exchange they're talking
about like you know loki's talking about
how oh
i oh yeah i come from asgard what's
weird about that and they talk about
life and how like
we we don't we don't know what
everyone's life is like and stuff like
that and then
mobius starts talking about like yeah i
was born here i'm lucky
i was born here i got to live this like
pretty safe life and
and to add to that maybe that is loki
trying to get away from like the chaos
that is
his you know space drama family of
asgard and and
jodenheim and him wanting to be you know
have something a little more day-to-day
maybe
maybe that is loki i like kind of like
that hey
i'm just i'm all not mobius is loki
train hardcore i don't know why it's
i just feel it in my bones but yes it
would be great for like a cinematic
twist
to be like oh you've been working with
yourself this entire time but then it
still would be so like upsetting to be
like
oh why would you hire this varian loki
when you're a loki couldn't you have
found yourself
there's no i i don't know that's the
only squirrel that i would have had
going around killing loki's
like maybe he's killing like the best
loki so he could be the superior loki
and then he's like lady loki he's like
oh she's killing and like i don't know
there could be this weird thing or he
could be using crazy he could be using
our loki he could be using our loki as
the like oh this
loki that we're with that keeps running
away when we're fighting stuff is the
one that's killing people
i'm not why else why is
of questions i have to it most of them
completely deflate the argument but i'm
not going to do that here because i want
to
hopefully see if this comes to pass
let's park up another tree though
uh could there be someone who we have
not met yet there's richard e grant
who's going to be playing
some role in this show like i just want
to know what do we think the origins of
this female variant are
is she an alternate timeline loki who
just kind of did like a sex
um chromosome switching randomly was
that the variant there uh was
did laffy bear a kid an altered timeline
who just happened to be female
is that really doing sylvie lushton what
do you guys think i like the idea of her
being silly
i i love the idea of her being sylvia
just because we all are like this is
lady loki this is lady loki
also in the second episode i know this
is rogue theory you guys we're supposed
to read too much into things
there's a part in the episode where
she's like please you're more like me
so what if there is an alternate
timeline where instead of in the
original comic books where silvia's just
like
uh like how wanda brought her kids in is
like a piece of
a loki where it's reversed where loki's
a piece of her
and so she's just like you're i'm your
mother at the end of the day because we
also know that like hella is like
in mythology is like what his daughter
or well like there's different like it's
like the daughter yeah there's like a
sister a daughter a partner
there's so many things that we there's
so many different timelines with loki
that we could
have this be like just completely
flipped and have silvie be the mom or
just like the
in a different timeline the she created
a loki
yeah you know what i'm saying so i love
that i know a lot of people have been
saying king i'm like oh no
kang uh but you know i i part of me
feels like it's a little too early
for that and i kind of think i do think
that there is something that i i believe
this loki is
our loki i watch a lot of doctor who and
it feels very like
like oh like this was meant to happen
all that kind of stuff um
i kind of think someone's playing loki
because we're seeing a lot of loki
going seeing you know his failures in
the in the main timeline seeing him
the death of his of his of his family of
asgard
all this stuff the death of himself so i
i do believe that
you know the variant is our loki in the
future because
they're trying i think that they're all
about right now loki's about redemption
we even hear owen wilson
um owen wilson you know the tva owen
wilson
like talking about him you know how he's
just like this broken child all this
stuff
and i think that someone is playing uh
you know the variant to kind of
do these acts to save
what now is asgard because there's new
asgard on earth and we're seeing a lot
of rocks core
and i'm thinking that it's actually
gonna it's i think it's the person at
top
is the ceo of as of uh rox roxon uh
dario
agar uh who oh sure i kind of think that
because in the comics uh you know jason
aaron's run deals all this it's really
great
um you know daryl agger messes with thor
and deals with
new asgard and kind of manipulates
everything to like the fall of asgard
and like all this kind of stuff uh i
kind of think we're gonna see
dario sooner than later we're seeing a
lot of rocks on everywhere and i kind of
think that this is
he's gonna be playing the cards to get
loki to like mess with the time variant
as um
you know the tva to like you know and
he's
they're gonna want to do it to save
asgard and redeem
themselves oh i like that idea
makes a lot of sense thanks yeah
we're talking time it's all weebly
wobbly anyways you know i mean
you know the deal yeah it might be okay
but i think this would be really fun
personally so you think that ultimately
like asgard is the like
heart and soul of this i do i think new
asgard specifically
new asgard yeah i don't not the one in
oklahoma yeah i don't think that loki is
gonna not go to new asgard
i don't think i think we're gonna see
you know oh this is what
has become like this is what you know
they're they are thriving they are doing
this and then someone's going to come in
and mess with things like
i want to step in and like you know i
know the ins and outs of the tva let me
deal with this
i like the idea of asgard being that
stronger than the like the tva versus
asgard essentially
like it's just like the tva is so big
and it's like well i'm doing all this
for asgard so
it's kind of sad that like you know he
loki wouldn't do this for
and i'm you know that's why he was blood
you know he never
would no way [ __ ] about you
trying to destroy you in the first one
he was just going to blast the bi
rifle yeah
that's a good one that's a rogue theory
that's a rogue
uh jessie you have any uh thoughts on
who could be a villain or do you think
it's gonna be
oh yeah i said just that i liked sylvia
i don't think it's yeah no i just okay
so that's a different theory but
i i i think i'm sticking with my guns
which is kind of vague but we're also
only on the second episode where on the
last rogue theory i was like the tva is
ultimately gonna be the big bad
um they're obviously like pushing this
narrative that like
loki has to be good he can't be the hero
so they're like
we need you to fix all this [ __ ] like
you you can't be you can't die a hero
you're
our timeline or you're messing up my
time i'm sorry i forget you guys have to
bleep things out
and so you're messing up the timeline
but um
side note now as we're getting further
in there's more people talking online
i also don't think hang the conqueror is
coming but
we can't act like um
ravone uh his wife yeah
we can't act like she's not there like
right we can't
i feel like not enough people are
talking about the fact that she's there
in this series
and there's gonna be something i don't
know if it's gonna be the same thing
that happened in doctor strange where
we're like
she's been lied to this entire time by
the tva which makes her turn
but it's like we i don't know i
i don't know i don't want to say that
she's a bad person but i think she's
gonna be so
she's going to be like um um she's going
to be like oh my gosh
falcon in the winter soldier she's going
to be like uh captain oh my god captain
america the new
john walker she's going to be like so
yeah she's going to be so
blinded by the tva that she's just going
to be doing bad things so i think like i
don't think she's ult i think the tva
ultimately is bad maybe that umbrella is
like encompassing her in it as well
because it's just like now i'm seeing
her more that i'm like
she's gonna do something like she's
gonna do
something when she picked up her like
her freaking stick
whatever you want to call that weapon um
i was like
she's pushing herself in this to try to
fix it but she's gonna make it worse
yeah i think she might be an unwitting
uh threat
uh like the fact that she's been this
judge for the tba i think we can all
agree that tva is at least flawed
in its design outright corrupt or male
intentional okay
but i think she's just like carrying out
she's just following orders she's doing
her job
what if she's not and she might have to
make a moral choice at some point as
i'll say what it but then i think that's
too close to every i it always comes
back to me with like i think it's too
close to what happened with shield with
the situation of like
oh what if someone's in there acting
like sophie did have a mobius loki
would that be too close to like the
whole shield and hydra situation of like
someone's in here
they're all lmds we're talking about
life model decoys
yeah i feel like
we're talking it out we're talking about
the fcu is gonna do lmds but i don't
know i feel like we're doing secret
invasion soon
and we're doing like some variants and
all that stuff like i
i feel like in loki's like a
shapeshifter i feel like marvel's just
like whatever at this point
like you know things aren't what they
seem sometimes and like that's okay
right right so yeah well feige said this
was really important for the future of
the mcu so that's well probably because
all the branches of timeline so we just
created the multiverse right
that's what that meant in the mcu we
have now loki
the loki variant has created the
multiverse or
recreated and we don't know how many
times how many doors that you
oh there was a multiverse first there
was the war yeah like it's just the
multiverse now is just like this one we
don't know where she's going multiverse
is still
existing it's just not allowed to grow
anymore which is are we
supposed to assume that she lady loki
has been going into
every door and making every time bomb
well
no i mean i think it remains we have
four more episodes the
like they may successfully prune most of
these i think
or it could get worse caused by someone
else or it could all get completely
unraveled and then
someone trying to restart the sacred
timeline makes a multiverse of madness
you know
uh i don't think the show is not done
there's still a lot more left to
mess up i'm kind of locked in
lasered in on what loki said about about
going to the different
every every time point they went to was
uh some sort of disaster
right maybe maybe this loki is trying to
prevent some sort of big disaster that's
meant to happen in a timeline
like in our present or something and the
tva won't allow it because it's supposed
to happen
a kind of avengery i don't know is that
maybe that's
it ties into your first theory of maybe
that's why they're making sure that like
not ragnarok but a new asgard
doesn't go under and all of them are
their souls are all spurted all over the
place maybe there is a loki
yeah because there's a lot of guys
there's a lot of crazy
you know asgardian realms crap that
happens so like i'm sure there's
there's so many disasters that that you
know loki could be
actually trying to prevent and throwing
the scent off by like doing it
doing all this stuff everywhere else i
don't know i think that's a great idea
and that's and that's a point that's
gonna get you
a rogi my friend that plus your dario
agger
so you win this round matt
uh but there's still another
conversation i want to have in a moment
first
some uh announcement uh over at new
rockstarsmerch.com we have unveiled the
fourth shirt design and our limited
edition latest obsession series loki
out of time buying the latest obsession
shirt will give you the ability to leave
a message on our inside marvel loki
after show
with either a shout out or your own
rogue theory and it'll show up on screen
during the show
and we've got a full lineup of loki
inspired merch included an augmented
reality shirt miss minute stickers tba
buttons and other cool stuff that hasn't
even been released
yet so go find it all over at new
rockstars newrockstarsmerch.com and we
want to thank
stamps.com for sponsoring this episode
are you still going to the post office
and paying full
price for postage well thanks to
stamps.com you don't have to anymore
mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups right to your computer whether
you're a small office sending invoices
a side hustle etsy shop shipping out
orders or just navigating this hybrid
work life
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
no wonder one million businesses choose
stamps.com for their mailing and
shipping
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off
with stamps.com you'll get discounts up
to 40 off post office rates and up to 66
off ups shipping rates stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you time and money so
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with promo code
rogue
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top
of the home page and type in rogue at
stamps.com promo code roguestamps.com
never go to the post office again
we also want to thank better help for
sponsoring this episode
is there something interfering with your
happiness preventing you from achieving
your goals
yeah you know like uh hey you lose a lot
of sleep when you're trying to find all
the easter eggs in loki and sometimes
you need that sleep and then you know
the things that you miss start to weigh
on you and you just need someone to talk
to well better help
is a great person to talk to because
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online
the service is available for clients
worldwide and has a broad range of
expertise available
which may not be locally available in
many areas
so log into your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so that they can
make it easy and free to change
counselors
if needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today visit betterhelp.com
rogue that's better h-e-l-p and join the
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
special offer for the rogue theory
audience get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
rogue let's move on to some spider-man
news there's this tweet this week from
sony argentina that caused a bit of a
stir because it shows the logo
for the upcoming spider-man no way home
film with a glitching
logo that many say is reminiscent of
spider-man into the spider-verse
so could this be hinting at a connection
between two different film universes or
is this maybe the presence of jimmy
fox's electro
causing everything to glitch what does
this mean
go rogue my baby god i hope so i hope to
god that they're gonna cross over into
the spider verse
with you know whatever live-action sony
spider-verse plans that they're doing
because
into the spider-verse is fantastic and
like they've already set
in at the end of inspired verse one they
do set up you know this this
greater spider-verse adventure so like
if that spider-verse adventure ties into
whatever they're doing
in their way home let's get it i'm all
about it um so
i think that that's there is a
possibility there i don't see why not
but
the time like in terms of like the
release of these films
sort of line up and like it's if in like
sony seems
full speed ahead with their spider-verse
plane so maybe this could actually be
i think it could i think it could very
well be a spider-verse tease i do think
that it's going to be related to
the multiverse uh and i think that
spider-verse
miles and peter's everyone's multiverse
is part of that
i don't think it's gonna be directly
we're gonna i don't think we're gonna
see
as much you know of like miles and stuff
into this i think it's gonna just be
like
like oh this exists within that scope i
don't think we're gonna get that just
yet but i do think
it's it's uh like part of it's like part
acknowledging that it does exist within
that world
but i don't think we're gonna see like
miles and stuff yet does that
does that make sense yeah no i i think i
understand what you're saying like
you're saying that like the uh the into
the spider verse
like whatever they're doing is gonna be
it might be referenced in in a live
action type deal
but like it's it's pretty much its own
separate thing yeah i do think it's
gonna be directly correlated to electro
though from amazing spider-man i
really do i think that's like the
connection he's coming in from a
multiverse maybe
you know i mean people know peter parker
spider-man so that's gonna tap into some
he's gonna reach out to someone for help
maybe doctor strange or whatever but
it's gonna
cause some sort of risk which will allow
you know which will bring electoral over
i think that's that's the
electro is the thread there i don't
think we're going to see just yet i do
think that spider versus the movie will
have a cameo of some sort i think
they're going to go there but i don't
think no way home is
i don't think no way home is oh got it
okay yeah that makes sense i think
just because sony is definitely
developing its own thing with uh the
animated version with
uh that uh world uh i wouldn't be
surprised
if somehow they start to cross-reference
each other uh but i do think it's
pretty possible that in the live-action
side of things we might get a character
named miles morales introduced
i think sony should do it sooner rather
than later because that is a fascinating
character
and he needs to be in live action do you
think it's going to be um
related to aaron davis uh uh uh donald's
lover
they already did the homework they
already established a character named
miles who's donald glover's nephew
living in this universe they could just
cast him but you're thinking it's going
to be
your thing it's going to be that miles
from the from our mcu universe not
on different miles right well yeah it
would be if if no way home is
mcu yeah it's it's in this weird kind of
venn diagram overlap between sony's
thing but it's technically mcu yeah
there could be a possibility that doc
ock and him are variants
that are now jumping timelines um or
jumping out
no i think that is 1 000 what is going
to happen
because electro died in his movie like
that jb fox electro is dead
and i think that whatever whatever
characters we are going to get
are going to be some type of variant you
guys are just blowing my mind you guys
are so great
that's amazing i love that no matter i
just want to see that in some form
that's amazing well it'd be funny
or not funny but it'd be fun if like the
opening is like not even an opening but
the when the villains are appearing and
no way home it's just like
shock lightning from the sky and out
drops just electro and
that would be cool i made it um i made
it to this timeline
i made it but um no i i i think i was
like
i really did believe i was like of
course it was a connection i watched the
clip i watched the electric
part and it does look the same as the
spider versus animation when
it says like sony studios so i did
believe that those were connected but
listening to matt talk
i don't think it's connected that's true
i agree i don't
yeah i think it's it's definitely most
likely not going to connect to any
animated stuff but like i think it'd be
fun it's probably just
it's doing exactly what it's meant to do
it's getting us talking about the movie
before any trailers come out keep it
fresh and relevant you know i mean
it's just a red herring you know it's
like ah all right great theories
everyone let's move on to
rogue question uh so our question today
is a quiet place too
was the top movie in the box office last
week has become the first movie of 2021
to make 100 million dollars
so what is the quietest way that they
can celebrate their accomplishments
oh oh oh i think they should do a silent
disco
they're so unsettling when you don't
have the headphones in
i like it but then when you take them
off it's that immediate instant of like
this is the weirdest thing i've ever
been to
i got a real real weird one uh
i kind of think they've been working
hard you know i i don't know if they
shot the third one yet but
look they need a break so they're all
going to go to one of those like
sensory like depraved rooms that's like
there's like a little bit of water
and they're just going to lie there's
those things they're so good but then
like the
but then like they're each going to go
to each other's rooms and like just like
asmr like
you did really great walk away
and then they're they're going to take
turns you know what i mean that's a
really fun one
you know what i'm just going to be
that's so funny let's just do like a
whole a mind pinata party
it's just like there's no actual stuff
it's just like it's a fake pinata
fake stick and you're just swinging just
to have it all
a fake it's a fake stick no one talks
it's just
you think
when they eat the imaginary food come on
man it's all about the power of
imagination
i do want to see all three but
unfortunately we can only have one
winner and the winner is going to be
matt this episode uh congratulations man
and uh uh thank you to all three of you
for your theories a lot of great
conversation here happened for loki i
can't wait to see episode three
uh but that is it for this episode of
rogue theory uh thank you to all three
of our
guests jessica clements mt matt acevedo
follow
all of them on their social medias uh
and support their various projects
you can support our channel by checking
in with our new loki themed merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe here on youtube and we'll see
you next time bye everybody
[Music]
you